Joe comida allah sawas welcome not till
Bush's first Academy foreign coach Don
see also of slave divorce a Macomb
Stokely disturb the daughters of
Sephora's Nobel Prize in Literature
calculated no ordinary cleaner in nan
Giorgio inalienable SME telepath will be
a Maxima for multi veering in a valid
court nobel preset literature or sugar
and retreat until dealers then
canadensis capture factor and Alice
Monroe
then then some tidak Novell constants
master a punt and in English the Nobel
Prize in Literature for 2013 is awarded
the Canadian author Alice Munro master
of the contemporary short story
[Applause]
[Music]
so mr. secretary Peter England I would
first of all like to congratulate you on
what I think is going to be a very
popular price yes I hope so Alice Monroe
she's in radius now and she has written
exclusively short stories as far as you
understand yes well she have written one
book it's a collection of stories
regarding the same dealing with the same
people and she has also written one of
my personal favorites is a a book she
wrote I think it came out 2006 which is
called the view from Castle Rock which
is sort of a hybrid between a history
fact and fiction where she investigates
her own family background going back to
to Scotland and so on and I don't know
what you call that one but besides these
two once she has only written the short
stories yes I read it now and then over
the years and you are struck I'm struck
by the fact that she moves electric
rather small world it's Canadian it's
that the back backwater towns and so on
could you say something about Amelia oh
yes oh yes a she it is almost
exclusively what happens almost
exclusively it takes place its
southwestern Ontario is on the edge of
some awkwardly a job of Canada is a very
flat rural area with broad rivers and
small towns and that's that's Harley you
there that's where she finds her
subjects where she finds her people then
once in a while she she can go out and
do something very much else because she
has she's really a brew author but I
think she has everything she needs in
this small patch of world that that is
her looking up at Albemarle County
and one of the words you find when you
read reviews of your books is is the
word ambiguity that is she's fascinated
by it a sort of sliding feeling between
people and psychology that it's put on
its head can you comment a little bit on
that what I think she is is very good at
capturing these different modes in
people not feeling you know a bit
sitting on the fence I think no one has
better deconstructed the central model
myth of romantic love not just saying
that it means they so it means that but
showing that people can be very few very
very different things about about it
there is a quotation from one more short
stories yeah it was a miracle it was a
mistake
it was what she dreamed of it was not
what she wanted and having this ability
to pick out decent people not knowing
exactly how they should react and so on
she is a fantastic portrayal of human
beings small people big feelings as they
say just one more question she's now in
her 80s and she said that she is going
to stop writing do we have any comment
on that
ah I don't know she has you should know
she has written since the early 50s
trouble writing because the first 10 20
years she was a home housewife helping
her husband with the business and so on
and she has done a really marvelous job
what she has done is quite enough it's
quite enough to get a Nobel Prize if she
wants to stop writing that's her own
that's her own decisions there was a
small book published called real life or
a dear life it's your life July yes and
in it there is a tools over or the north
or biography in the end which is very
interesting a couple of author buy over
biographical checks it gives number of
clues
to the the entire so thank you again
then and commutations on a very very
popular price I think